NARRATOR: We speed across
M87, A gigantic galaxy
55 million light
years from Earth.
At its heart lies a supermassive
black hole, M87 star.
It is the first and only
black hole ever photographed.
We want to find out how
M87 star grew so large,
what lies inside, and how
it controls the galaxy.
5,000 light years out from
the supermassive black hole,
we get our first sign
of the danger ahead.
We see giant holes carved out
of the galaxy, starless void's
thousands of light years wide.
PAUL M. SUTTER: As we approach
we can see that wreckage
littered around the vicinity.
It's like entering
the lair of the dragon
and seeing the bones of all the
explorers who came before you.
NARRATOR: What cataclysmic
force tore these giant cavities
in the galactic gas clouds?
As we fly next to
a brilliant shaft
of energy thousands of
light years from M87 star,
we get a clue.
It's a deadly
stream of radiation
shooting out across the galaxy.
A jet.
This jet looks
like a searchlight,
or a beam from a lighthouse.
You're seeing this
monumental thing
screaming out of the black
hole, blasting out radiation.
MAX TEGMARK: When I first saw
a photo of a jet I was like,
whoa, am I like, misreading
the scale of this image?
Because there was
this crazy "Star Trek"
like beam just coming out.
NARRATOR: In 1918
American astronomer,
Heber Curtis described the jets
as a curious, straight ray.
A century later,
observatory images reveal
they pulsate with energy.
PAUL M. SUTTER: The
images show knot's,
and clumps in these jets.
They show that it's just
not smooth and nice,
that there's been a history
of violence inside this jet.
NARRATOR: This
violent energy pushes
the knots along the beams.
The knots reveal the
speed of the jets.
It's like looking at
a fast moving train.
Rail cars of the same color
blur into one continuous image.
But, different colored cars
stand out against the others.
It's the same with the
knots moving along the jets.
So, we can figure out how
fast the jets are really moving
by looking at knots
of material coming
out from near the black hole.
NARRATOR: When astronomers
measured the speed of two
knots, they got a big surprise.
One is moving at 2.4
times the speed of light,
and the other is moving over
6 times faster than light.
How could this possibly be?
As weird as the physics
around a black hole is,
that's not actually happening,
nor is it allowed to happen.
PAUL M. SUTTER:
Nothing can actually go
faster than the speed of light.
So obviously, we're
missing something here.
NARRATOR: The knots may seem
to break the speed of light.
But, the universe is
just playing with us.
It's really just a
consequence of the fact
that a lot of this
jet is pointed
toward us, pointed partially
toward the observer on Earth.
MAX TEGMARK: That in a sense,
the sort of optical illusion,
tricks you into thinking
it's moving faster.
NARRATOR: It's a simple
trick of the light.
A bit like the way a
spoon in a glass of water
looks bent, and distorted.
The impossibly fast
speed of the jet
is just an illusion
of perspective.
PAUL M. SUTTER: From
our perspective,
it looks like the
whole thing is moving
towards us faster than light.
But really, it's just cruising
along very, very fast.
MAX TEGMARK: The
Jets aren't actually
breaking the laws of physics.
They're pushing up against it,
they're going at 99.999995%
the speed of light.
Imagine the energies
necessary to accelerate
this entire jet to that speed.
NARRATOR: So, what could
produce enough energy
to blast jets across the galaxy
at close to the speed of light?
There is a clue far ahead.
The Jets shoot out from a
tiny, brightly glowing object.
This is where things go nuts.
This is the center
of the action.
This is where the
real stuff happens.
NARRATOR: A ring
of super hot gas,
and dust whirls around the
supermassive black hole.
It's called the accretion disk.
And it shines a billion
times brighter than the sun.
CHIARA MINGARELLI: If you had a
ringside seat next to M87 star,
you would probably be
fried very, very fast.
But, if you were some, you
know, magical being and could
survive anything, and
if you had, you know,
million SPF sunscreen, and
really, really great sunglasses
what you would see is this
enormously bright vortex
of gas swirling this dark void.
NARRATOR: This
bright vortex spins
around the
supermassive black hole
at over two million
miles an hour.
So, there's a
tremendous amount
of friction as material
moving slower and faster
rubs against each other.
That's what's
heating the disk up,
and that's what's
causing it to glow.
NARRATOR: Scientists think
that the intense energy
of the accretion disk is
the source of the jets.
The hot swirling gas
and dust produces
powerful magnetic fields.
As the disk spins, it twists
up the magnetic fields
at the poles of the black hole.
Energy builds.
Finally, the
magnetic fields can't
contain the energy any longer.
They snap, and blast the
jets out into the galaxy.
Even many light years
away on the ship,
we can see this violent
release of energy.
It's like the universe's
biggest fireworks display.
Two jets streaking out
of M87 stars poles.
One shooting away into the
distance, the other racing
past our ship.
We're at a safe distance,
other things are not.
So, when these
jets shoot outward
from this supermassive
black hole,
they don't shoot
outward into nothing.
If a jet hits a gas
cloud, it annihilates it.
It just punches a
hole right through it.
GRANT TREMBLAY: It's like a
train going down a snowy track,
right?
The gas is like the snow, and
the jets are like this freight
train plowing across it.
NARRATOR: But here, a
freight train traveling
at close to the speed of light.
Smashing into clouds
of gas, lighting
our way to M87 Star as we
follow the trail of destruction.
There is evidence of
similar destruction
across the universe.
In the Cygnus A galaxy,
supermassive black hole jets
have caused damage
on a colossal scale.
GRANT TREMBLAY: In
many ways, Cygnus A is
like a cosmic shooting gallery.
You see this crime scene,
this beautiful mess.
HAKEEM OLUSEYI: So,
when this jet comes out
of the nucleus of Cygnus A, it's
going to encounter gas clouds.
At that point,
shock waves set up.
And this jet just rips
right through this material,
sending shock waves
in every direction,
creating absolute chaos.
It's hard to believe
how much devastation
these jets can cause.
They're punching a hole in the
gas 100,000 light years wide.
I mean, that's, that's the
scale of an entire galaxy.
NARRATOR: As we head towards
the center of the M87 galaxy,
we enter hostile territory.
The closer to the supermassive
black hole we travel,
the more dangerous it gets.
As we approach the
central core of M87,
we start to feel it.
All this energy, all
this ferociousness
is powered by that black hole.
NARRATOR: Intense winds
start to buff at the ship.
They push away vital gas,
quenching star birth.
Could these winds end up
killing the galaxy, and M87 Star
itself?